[Music]
animus is a 2019 Netflix psychological
Spanish horror film that may leave some
viewers scratching their heads there's a
lot to unpack from the ending of the
film so to try and clear things up I've
put together my thoughts on it as well
as the events that happen throughout the
movie there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you don't want to know anything
about the ending of the film then I
highly suggest that you turn off now but
for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to okay so in order to fully
understand the ending of the film we
must first uncover the identity of Alex
whilst I've seen many people wondering
whether Alex was a ghost spirit or even
guardian angel I think that is pretty
apparent that Alex is none of these
instead Alex is an imaginary friend
or rather a separate personality that
Bram invented in order to deal with the
abuse that he suffered from his father
as a child
those with split personalities are often
victims of trauma and this is a film
that is very much about the invention of
another personality in order to deal
with events that may cause pain for
example are the cases of this in recent
pop culture include the film's split
which deals with a boy who was so badly
abused as a child that he invented
several personalities in order to allow
them to take the brunt of the punishment
without affecting his own psyche too
much similar to this a Batman has been
said to be a personality that Bruce
Wayne invented in order to show that he
was more than a traumatized boy that
watched his parents murdered in front of
him traumatic experiences often split
the psyche so that the brain can
disassociate with things and this is
what Bram had to do to handle the abuse
that was dealt to him in the film
it appears that Alex has become a real
person but this is to to the psychosis
of Braun we see hints towards this
second personality throughout the film
most notably in the psycho poster psycho
was of course centered around the
character Norman Bates who too had a
split personality in that film and
Norman
there's several people under the belief
that is actually his mother doing the
deed and this allows him to distance
himself mentally from the crime similar
to this in anima the other personality
suppressing certain aspects of a
scenario happens in the case of Brahms
father's death we learn that it was in
fact Brahms mother that killed his
father and he only managed to end up
with the car keys because Alex picked
them up put them in his pocket and then
suppress this memory so that there was
confusion over the event the film asks
the question what defines a real person
and if so does Alex fit under that
definition if you define a real person
as someone that has their own
personality and is able to operate and
do things then yes Alex is real however
and this is a big however she only
exists in Brahms mind and the two have
to share a body throughout the film we
also see different colors used to
portray different emotions and these
traffic lights share symbolism with
their real-world counterparts with green
meaning Brown is safe amber meaning the
Alex's and red meaning that they are in
danger it's a nice subtle touch that I
think adds a wealth of depth of the work
and does elevate it quite a bit
whilst I've seen many say that animus is
a confusing mess to me it does make at
least some sense though it definitely
requires a few rewatch --is to see how
things come together the film isn't
necessarily cut and dry nor should it be
there are lots of elements in there that
are put in deliberately to confuse the
viewer and make them second-guess there
are some students whilst animus isn't
necessarily for everyone I still did
enjoy the reveal and no I wouldn't
recommend it it still poses some deep
questions in regards to its ending so
what are your thoughts on animus and
what did he take from its ending I'm
completely open to being told I'm wrong
about things in it so if you disagree or
agree make sure you leave your thoughts
in the comments below if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my breakdown of
serenity which I think has the worst
movie twist of all time so give that a
click at the end of this video this is
the channel for people who are heavy
into horror so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best now see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you